Ricky Gervais couldn't be here tonight
so instead we're going to give this to
our friend Steve Carell
[Applause]
look at his stupid face
couldn't actually win one of his own so
he stole someone else's
our next presenters are two of the
funniest people in America
she stole the show on Saturday Night
Live then went on to create write and
start her own show 30 Rock
he was a jobbing actor
career not going that well if I'm being
totally honest who
who got his big break when I cast him in
a remake of a show that I created called
the office
he's now leaving that show and killing a
cash cow for both of us please welcome
the wonderful Tina fight and The
Ungrateful Steve Carell
[Music]
[Applause]
I love it
never gets old
Steve Corral is considered handsome
Ryan Wilson
you probably know me as the creator of
the office
no you don't do you you think Steve
Carell didn't
all he's brilliant isn't he Steve Corral
he's amazing as the bumbling office
manager where does he get his ideas from
let's play
idiotic thing to say with six billion
people on the planet how are they all
Gonna Love
one person a lot of them do I mean it
looks like an American population in the
office was it 10 million viewers I guess
10 million people watching him tune in
and see my name at the end of the credit
not really no because it wouldn't exist
without me and he wouldn't exist without
it
where is he over there in the front row
it's just
just in case you have to make a dash for
it
have you got it on you
I've heard you carry it around with
these are getting restaurants and stuff
I made you what don't I'm going off-road
everyone's getting nervous now there's
nothing on the auto queue I could do
anything this is live
I made you what you are and I get
nothing back
have you even been to see ghost town yet
no
I sat to Evan Almighty give me Miami
I'll come down there
give me it
article yeah I don't care I've got
nothing to lose here I'm a nobody here
where is it
yes she will stop yes you are yes you
are getting it
give me the Emmy
thank you
give me the Emmy
give me the Emmy
give me it
give me
thank you
right good
that's settled could you do what Ricky
does oh not in a million years why
um I think I would just get too skittish
I I play a Ricky Gervais character
perhaps but to actually go in front of
people and offend them to their faces I
don't think I I necessarily it doesn't
mean that I'm a better person it just
means that I certainly don't have that
kind of uh guts he it's funny he always
makes fun of me always
um and he he's he's also you know in a
personal way but very very sweet to me
like before one of these award shows he
pulled me aside and said hey I've got a
few things that I wanted to go after you
with is that okay like of course so he's
there is a side there is a gentler side
to him that people don't necessarily
he's such a lovely man though but he
thinks you're sweet because just to
clarify you go up to him before an award
someone and say I'm going to call you a
prick in a minute just to warn you but
if I told him what I was gonna say you
know if I had access to them I'd warn
everyone you know as I said I don't want
to drive a bad day you know it's not
it's not I've got nothing against people
it's great he's fantastic
um he's good because you know why he's
got he's nearly handsome he's got that
he's he's got he's he's like Bob Hope if
you look at him he's chiseled he's great
but he's got something he's got beady
eyes he's good I like him I like that
was a compliment by the way he's very
handsome I mean he's comediately
handsome he's not imposing he's not he's
not Bland he's um why are we going on
about oh good looking Steve corellis
what am I chop liver